let's do one more game and then i'm
gonna call it a day because i'm pretty
pretty spent
let's hope we get a good one okay next
game here we go
we're probably gonna get black here nice
and um as
as we had decided let's play the karaoke
and see uh
sorry let me just transition sorry
yeah okay i think we're good now
okay so c4 this is the first time we are
encountering
this move this is a move clearly white
is preparing
and grabbing the d5 square as
immediately as possible but uh that
doesn't mean we don't play d5 we still
play d5
this is a very likely to transpose into
the pawn off
the pawn of attack after e d cd and d4
white can also grab the pawn twice
that's a different line
what structure are both of these
variations
likely to lead to and it's three letters
the classic and i'm already wow flame
is ahead of the game iqp is correct
so we're likely going to get on iqp but
because he's thinking that tells me
maybe he hasn't
seen this or not is not too familiar
with the car con we will see
take stakes and e5
okay that is definitely not the way to
play
for many reasons one of which is that he
basically again gives us an ideal french
so in such situations we normally want
to bring the bishop out to f5 and then
go e6
but here we don't need to rush with
bishop f5
we can also uh well what else can we how
else can we develop
what's well that ideal french is a
french where our bishop is outside the
pawn chain
we can go knight c6 demon mentions the
interesting possibility of going d4
which is an idea that does exist in
certain
positions similar to this one the point
of that is that we
prevent white from going d4 we
essentially sever the connection between
the d and the e pawns
but but after d4 we also give the bishop
a nice developing square on c4
it's possible but let's not be too
adventurous here i just want to go
knight c6 and bishop f5
no reason for us to refrain from an
ideal french setup
when it's handed to us like this what's
up dukaia good to see you
yeah bishop f5 is right so bishop f5
and french players are like completely
in paradise here
literally in advanced french with the
bishop on f5 there is one
semi drawback which is that in the
french we have pawns on c5 and c3
and it is true that here uh we've
already traded on d4 so the knight has
this
natural developing square on c3 but
if you weigh the pros and cons it's
there isn't even a comparison
the fact that the bishop is outside the
pawn chain gives black a very
comfortable position i don't think black
is better here
i think the position is still equal but
white is the one who's got to be a
little bit more careful
to preserve that equality make sure his
pawn chain doesn't collapse so here
of course we play e6
yeah well sprinkles even when there is a
pawn on c3 there's also pawn on c5 they
cancel each other out
that's an important point the presence
of pawns on c5 and c3 does not make
the d4 pawn technically any weaker or
stronger
there's one more attacker and one more
defender it's just that black is the one
who holds the power
black is the one who knocks black can
decide when to take on d4 a
and b the knight on b1 doesn't have the
developing square c3
which is in black's advantage
okay i hope that makes sense
so a lot of players will have a very
hard time
figuring out what to do here with white
yeah g4 is interesting but it's not
dangerous g4 h4 will just go h5 and
prevent
white from going h5 it's not and white
will overextend himself
even further in that case and create
even more weaknesses
okay let's see and you can tell that
he's
a little bit out of his depth here
which is why these openings like the
karo khan and
uh you shouldn't play the hillbilly
attack openings like the karo khan or
the french
can be uh quite effective even you know
at this level because it's not that they
haven't
seen it before it's just that perhaps
it's not quite as well studied
all right so what to do here
first of all it's worthwhile to ask
ourselves the question
why not night before threatening knight
c2 knight c2 is not so easy to stop but
there is a reason
we don't want to go knight b4 and yes we
want to go queen b6
just like in the french because
unfortunately knight b4 exposes the king
to a check on b5 we certainly don't want
to bring the king up so we'll just have
to go
back with a knight who wants to do that
queen a4 is the same concept when a4 is
also very possible also forces the
knight back to c6
so we bring the queen out to b6 just
like we do in the french
putting significant pressure on the d4
pawn
unlike in the front well unlike in the
french our bishop is on f5
if one is even to talk about a drawback
to this
it is that this knight on uh we're gonna
have to be a little bit creative about
how we choose to develop this knife on
g8
in the french we often go to f5 here the
bishop is on f5
so we'll need to manage that situation
it's something i've talked about before
because it's a situation that does arise
quite frequently in the karaoke
and there are two or three ways of
resolving this
the first is sometimes people go knight
age six
in order to leave space for the dark
squared bishop and then castles
uh in parallel to that you can play
either knight cheese
knight h6 or 97 and then what maneuver
can you suggest
thank you gifting to d kyle what
maneuver can you suggest
to vacate that yeah five square for the
knight that's what we're going to do
here i want to just demonstrate this
and we're going to demonstrate this
yeah bishop g6 and 97 knight f5 we can
start with bishop g6
i like starting with either 97 or knight
h6
now if you look at knight h6 you should
be curious as to
why i'm not afraid of bishop takes h6
let's play knight h6 i hope he takes on
h6
so that i can demonstrate this if you've
been watching the speed run for a while
however you'll know that i showed a game
that i played myself with white
against a julio brown as an eager
grandmaster from peru
where uh i i sort of talked about why
it's not dangerous the bottom line is
because
his dark squared bishop is a very
important defensive piece without it
the pawn on d4 becomes a lot harder to
defend his entire position becomes a lot
looser
than a4 okay that's fine we can go queen
a5 check but
then bishop d2 the same goes for bishop
before chuck bishop before chuck looks
good
but he just goes bishop d2 and i don't
think the trade of dark squared bishops
is good for us
it's good if he gets his dark squared
bishop and trades it for our knight but
i want a key part archer bishop so
there's no need here to do anything
crazy
just drop the queen back to c7 or d8
queen c7 is what we're going to play now
let's begin by developing our bishop to
e7
okay now let's complete our regrouping
going bishop g6 and then knight f5
everything is in perfect place now our
knight has a home our bishop is a home
all of our pieces are developed save our
king we're going to castle
and then we're going to embark on the
middle game i have to compliment my
opponent he's
he's handling this very well um i don't
think we're better but we have a very
comfortable position
okay so first of all do we want to take
on e3
the case for that would be that we sort
of ruin this pawn structure but
is it a good idea to take on e3 no it
isn't
for two reasons the first is that that
bishop isn't going anywhere it's going
to be there on e3 for us if we want to
take it at a later point the second
reason
why open up the f-file for him why
eliminate a knight that's putting the d4
pawn under significant pressure
so instead let's begin by castling
that's the most flexible move
and the very typical idea french players
should be
more than familiar with this idea what's
a typical follow-up
you know every the pressure has reached
its apex how do we take it to the next
level
what's the move the move is of course f6
the move is f6 and i see no reason
to well i do see a reason to hold off on
that move if he goes f6
no actually no i don't let's go f6 let's
play f6 let's open up the center
there's some subtleties here that i
could talk about but let's keep things
pretty simple with f6 okay
knight b5 attacking the queen where
should we go where
should we go
we can go to b8 that's okay but
i kind of like the possibility of
dragging the queen back to b6 because
it sort of pins the knight to the pawn
it reinforces the pressure on d4
after ef6 bishop f6 look at how many of
our pieces will be trained on that pawn
i just feel like his position will be
very close to collapsing with so many
pieces trained on that d4 pawn
okay go karen
if he doesn't take we either go a6 or
remember nothing has happened to the
possibility of taking the bishop
and then taking the pawn that is why we
held off on that move
so that we are holding this over his
head
there's a very funny subtlety that i
just realized with the move a6
after a6 knight c3 is it possible to
take on b2
i missed this at first uh i'll be
completely honest
so imagine if we had played a6 he played
knight c3 taken
there's this pattern of going knight a4
well rook b1 blunders the knight on c3
but why is that a pin because that
knight on c3 is going to be hanging what
i meant is that knight a4 traps the
queen that's a puzzle rush theme
all right so he's got bishop d3 and now
it is time
for us to collect the harvest in what
order should we do things
now what you guys should see is that
the most obvious move here is to take on
e5
and after d takes c5 to take the bishop
when his position collapses
f takes e3 queen takes e3 we're gonna
win at least upon probably also a piece
but okay so f takes e5 from that
perspective is good
but after f takes c5 does white have any
additional options
does white have any additional options
after f65 he has bishop takes f5
let's continue calculating bishop takes
f5 bishop takes f5
and he can take back on e5 is that good
for white
or are we missing something so what i'm
saying is takes
takes takes takes
what happens at the end bingo
everybody should be able to see that
position the knight on b5
is hanging that's why it's so important
to note down
all the type 1 and type 2 undefended
pieces
precisely because you get these
variations that's one of the most common
reasons for blundering or miscalculating
is forgetting that a piece hangs
at the end of a line if you notice that
it's vulnerable
straight away it'll be easier not to
forget about it later benjamin to the
ray party of 53 welcome everybody
tail end of my stream guys i still
appreciate it though
we're doing some speed running and
having a great time thank you blackjack
for the prime
we are in the midst of a karaoke game
that is looking very very promising
doesn't that give white an attack on the
queen well no the bishop is gone
and if white takes d takes c5 then we
take black
white's bishop on e3 and his position
collapses i hope that makes sense
so either he takes the knight to stop
knight takes c3 and then his knight
hangs
or he takes on e5 and allows knight
takes e3
and that's the reason why i didn't want
to play a6 first
this knight while it may seem like a
bone in our throat it's actually an
asset
it's a very big asset because it burdens
white's defenders it burdens the bishop
now the bishop is not free to do other
things white is busted
white is really busted cyrux thank you
for the prime
on all of the support today by the way
is so much appreciated guys
thank you i'll talk about that later
though let's see what he does
is opening white's f file now fine
because we also have an open rook
yeah so that's one way of looking at it
we have an open rook
but it doesn't matter it's a moot point
because
we're winning a piece right you're
winning a piece
uh it's like you know someone offers you
a lottery ticket and says this is the
winning lottery ticket but
but there's a catch it's like what's the
catch well
um you know you're here's the envelope
with the lottery ticket but you're gonna
get a little paper cut while opening it
do you still want that lottery ticket
like nah man that's terrible i don't
want to get a paper cut
uh so you know you open the f file
that's a weird analogy i
this is only at 4 am while i make such
an analogy but you get what i'm saying
it's a moot point and that's sort of
that's the definition of a moot point
a cow's opinion
yeah concrete stuff outweighs uh these
positional advantages
taxes on the lottery winnings yeah i
okay but i think you understood the
meaning of the analogy
it's like we give him the f file but
that's so unimportant
in comparison to what we get in return
which is an extra piece
and you always have to weigh those
things right
oh well if it's the 18th century that's
not good
okay
all right we got a hype train skog's
three with a pram
thank you sir
thank you sir
nothing looking for am i trained he's
stunned well he's busted because we're
here we go demon with a 10 damn girl
demon with the 10 and chaser work with
the prime
on fire thank you i really appreciate it
demon
all right that is some phenomenal stuff
okay now we're talking about paper cuts
that seems to be a fun topic of
conversation i think everybody has their
like paper cut story
it's really confusing to me that we are
fine with having the white bishop
blocked for most of the game
whereas before we were talking about not
blocking their pieces wait a minute whoa
wait a minute
which piece are we blocking here what do
you mean the white bishop
the white bishop blocked in the king's
indian attack game
but you mean we were fine with blocking
it in the king's indian game but you're
saying that before i
i was railing on about how you shouldn't
block your pieces right
is that what your what the dissonance is
or is it
something specific to this game or is it
just a general question about other
games
i think you just walked away you may
have just walked away thank you slave
for 100.
so i'll talk about that yes
it applies here in the beginning of the
game
where does it apply like you mean knight
g7 the possibility of going knight g7
sorry i'm not trying to be difficult i'm
just not sure where where it is that
here we're
we're like not okay with blocking a
piece
yeah i think he's just done
b-town that's a pretty good that's a
pretty good spot to place the the
divider line yeah
well that's pretty interesting okay um
so let's have a look at the game you
guys have been
behaving yourselves
all right thanks again demon
for those 10.
uh oh and as i speak another five from j
rin damn girl all right
now we're talking thank you jayren for
the five really appreciate it
so we have a karo gun c6 d4
and c4 is reasonable
but after cd so after edc d
he can play d4 and of course transpose
into the into the pawn of variation
which
typically occurs with d4 and then c4
but it doesn't matter which move order
uh but the more independent line is edn
and cd
or cd and ed and here you don't want to
take on d5 immediately
for the relatively straightforward
reason that it's almost like a scandi
you allow white to play knight c3 with
tempo you want to take this pawn on your
own terms so you want to go knight f6
first
and then try to take it with a knight
and there's a lot of theory here
white can try to cling to the pawn with
bishop e5 check
in order to lure a piece onto d7 to make
it harder
to win that pawn so there's a lot going
on here but
black is fine in this line black
equalizes easily but it's a good line
for
you know one or two games uh
so e5 is is really the first culprit
which gives us that ideal setup
with a knight on c6 and the bishop on b5
is that because there's no e or b pawns
to protect yeah yes that's why it's
isolated so d4 bishop f5
knight c3 e6 this is all very obvious
again if knight b4 then he gives this
check and forces our knight back to c6
or queen a4
uh queen b6 why was d4 bad after e5 so
i talked about that in the moment it's
not bad
in fact i have a pretty good hunch that
perhaps the computer will like d4
it's not that it's bad it's more that i
wanted to showcase
the sort of typical way of punishing
this kind of move
and the drawback that i was a little bit
worried about is that it gave the bishop
this square
i didn't really want to allow that
knight c6 knight f3
this pawn is not an immediate danger of
being lost white can defend it in a lot
of different ways
so it's just sort of a different type of
position which i wasn't necessarily
fully behind having also why can play e6
later and sacrifice that one
so in any case i just thought this was
simpler d4 bishop f5
knight c3 e6 knight f3 and queen b6
so we're piling on the pressure and i'm
going to segue dark knight if you're
still here i
i figured out how to answer your
question i'm going to segue into that
so once again the key problem that we
have to resolve here
is uh the proper way to share
limited resources on the king side
between three minor pieces
we have only a couple of squares we're a
little bit cramped and we've got to make
sure all of the pieces have their moment
in the sun
and so we came up with a setup knight h6
why are we not afraid of this there's
many reasons
these doubled pawns look a little bit
unpleasant
but they're not really anything uh big
of a deal
we get the g-file we get an attack on b2
this pawn becomes harder to defend
all these things put together should
make it quite clear that this is a very
bad
bargain for white
uh i would consider castling long yes i
would definitely
you can castle short in such positions
and tuck your king on h8 that's not out
of the question
i would probably begin by not castling i
would probably go rook g8 and see what
white does
most likely i would castle long and then
very quickly go king ba although that is
a little bit dangerous but that's what
i'd say i'm not gonna make any promises
though
all options are on the table there's no
like correct way of looking at it
yeah so light shade no 97 is also very
possible
uh it it depends on the concrete
circumstances sometimes the knight also
goes out to g6 you'll you'll also see
this
um and that's a benefit of y97 it's a
little bit more flexible
so not really i i wanted to keep the
bishop open for now
um and dark knight
the concept of blocking pieces i'll get
to that in just a moment but
there's usually going to be if i'm
afraid to block a piece
it's usually because there's something
concrete that i'm afraid of
for example i was a little bit worried
about knight b5 here
trying to get to d6 right so it's not
that the bishop is permanently blocked
in
it's just that i'm a little worried
about this concrete move and
it's really nothing to worry about you
can go knight g6 and now the bishop is
in time
to protect the square but i didn't want
to allow it
knight a4 queen c7
maybe castles be four bishop d2 um
bishop b7
yeah my bishop is trapped but it's
impossible to attack it
bishop d2 and now again we have this
knight on h6
we really want that knight to be on f5
so the bishop
very courteously kindly drops back says
all right
uh make space for the night and this
segways me into answering
that question dark knight run up which
is like how do i decide when i'm worried
about
on a general level when i'm worried
about blocking a piece when i'm not
and why am i often not worried about it
i if you guys have paid careful
attention to how i talk about things
one of the things i worry about the
least is blocking a piece with another
piece
so a good way to understand this is a
good framework to understand this is
static versus dynamic
uh advantages or or on the opposite end
drawbacks
um so like a static defect and the
words that you should associate with
that is temporary likely to be temporary
and likely to be permanent
a static weakness is a weakness
just you understand that word that is
likely to be relatively
permanent or long-term not necessarily
but very likely to be so for example a
weak square
or a pair of doubled pawns is a static
weakness
which is not to say you can't undouble
your pawns or you can't
through some transformation of the
position uh
make that square a non-weakness again
you you usually can
but that doesn't happen too often and uh
that requires some sort of
you know relatively significant
transformation of the position
contrast that with dynamic factors and a
dynamic factor
usually refers to piece placement
because peace placement is
generally speaking going to be temporary
if you have a piece that's blocking
another piece
you're you're usually it's going to be
within your power to move this knight
away and unblock the bishop and you can
do that relatively on demand
so there's obviously exceptions to that
rule there are situations
when your piece is permanently blocked
in by another piece and a more static
factor is a piece that is blocked in by
pawns
right so if you've got a piece that's
locked in
behind your own pawns that can be a much
harder situation to get out of we have
seen
that kind of situation on on several
occasions i've shown you a couple of
games
with that sort of thing happening
um and one example of that is uh
is this my game against ownershook
this position from that game
one sec this position from that game
where the bishop on a8
is well it's the most miserable bishop
of all time
and this is a static weakness right the
bishop can never literally never unbury
itself unless this pawn is taken
and then black goes c5 and that never
happened
so this is a jailed bishop but if you
contrast that if
if the pawn on c6 were replaced by a
knight then it would be within my power
to move the knight away
so that's the key difference and
generally speaking you should be less
worried about dynamic weaknesses and
deficiencies
than you should be about static so if
you're weakening a square
if you're weakening your king
permanently by pushing out a pawn
that's something which you should take
very very seriously but blocking in a
piece with another piece
unless that piece which you blocked is
participating very directly in the game
it's fulfilling some sort of significant
role or you can do it without blocking
because it's obviously not a pleasant
thing to do i wouldn't worry too much
about it
as long as you can sort of chart a
course
and as long as you can determine that at
some later point
you will be able not to unblock it in
sort of a timely fashion i don't know if
i'm
sort of stumbling over my words thank
you b-town for the gift
to uh to light shane but thinking about
it in terms of
static versus dynamic am i making a
temporary weakness
or am i making a permanent weakness the
more temporary it is
the more okay with it you can kind of be
and
of course the knight on f5 is
essentially free to go
at almost any moment okay there's a lot
more to talk about on that on that front
but consider that an introduction
the castle's knight c3 he didn't do
anything
very wrong until the i mean i think
knight b5 is the first step in the wrong
direction
i think he should have just taken and
accepted a slightly worse
and passive position so
we've got this tremendous pressure on d4
we can bring the rook into e8
it's also quite interesting to take with
a pawn here
what plan can we associate with this
move how should we
proceed and this plan is very aggressive
we do have an opportunity i think to
attack white's king
yeah we can go king h8 rook jade we can
go for an attack
and sky bobbles to your question just
because you castle short
as i like to say does it mean you can't
castle on the king side or you can't
attack on the king side
the king still has a nice little sliver
of
paradise on eight shape uh and it
cooperates it shares the space with the
rook that's doing the attacking
uh you should be careful about that the
king is not like perfectly safe but it
still has this one pawn that it can act
that it can use as a cover okay
um so once he went knight b5
the decisive mistake was bishop d3 i
don't know what he could have i mean i
think he could have still taken
although this is the worst version
because this knight is so fragile we can
go a6
and uh after bishop d3 fe just to recap
after de-93 queen e3 we fork
the king of the bishop and if he first
takes on f5 as we calculate it
knight on b5 is now hanging he has to
move the knight back he should have done
this the game is not entirely over but
now we can take on b2
because with this bishop being gone we
can simply slide either to c2
we can slide it back to b5 black is
going to be at the very least two funds
up
with just total domination
um all right
so that's about it that's how the game
concluded he obviously timed out here
any questions about this game can we
play f6 earlier before castling in some
cases yes you can
can white minimize the damage by
retreating the bishop on e3
you mean in this position well then we
fork the bishop in the knight
yeah why i can't say this white is lost
white is already lost i'm quite sure you
can check on the computer
what the relatively best option is but
no matter what white does he's gonna be
at the very least i think dupont's down
h6 bishop h7 is a very viable idea no
definitely
i've seen that before as well absolutely
yeah minus three so he is losing
not here thorvald i mean already he's
lost what if opponent tries to exchange
queens
well it doesn't do any remember you're
also threatening e4 the the source of
danger comes from this
as well as this as well as this there's
too much to deal with here
how is the white bishop forked in the
check with the queen oh sure
so this is a check and the bishop on d3
is attacked by two pieces and only
defended by one
so that is the definition of a fork two
pieces are attacked at once
and oftentimes i think coaches teach a
fork as
necessarily a night fork forks can be
done with any piece
this is also a double attack double
attacks and forks
are virtually interchangeable i think
forks has sort of a night like
connotation
uh you often associate a fork with like
a knight on c7 but
that is not necessarily the case
of course charging glad to hear that
all right guys 4 a.m i i do want to get
a good amount of sleep i've got
my second shot tomorrow so um i don't
want to be a zombie
i'll see you guys later take care
everybody and have a great start to the
weekend a great
friday bye
[Music]